The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: So you
guys walked in just in time.
So today's topic is slightly
different, but before we start,
you asked a question
last time, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: And
what's your name again?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
[? Kalpesh, ?]
OK, again, so [? Kalpesh, ?]
my friend here, asked
me a question.
And I think you asked it in
the lecture before the quiz.
So I answered it.
I guess you were not convinced.
So he asked me again just
before the quiz started.
I told him, well, wait until
actually we, the class,
have convened, so we can
all discuss it together.
So I was thinking how
to answer his question.
And then I decided it was a
really interesting question.
So I made some additional
slides to discuss the topic
that he asked.
And these slides are
not on the website,
so don't look for them.
You cannot find them, even
though I will probably post
them anyway.
But for now, you
just have to watch
and participate
in the discussion,
and see what happens.
So [? Kalpesh ?]
asked the following,
when I started,
actually, the class, I
claimed that optical rays have
to satisfy Fermat's principle.
So therefore, they must always
go where their path is minimal.
So in the case of a GRIN,
I use the notation here
where the gray area in
the slide corresponds
to high index of refraction.
The sort of whitest
area is low in index.
So this is like a typical GRIN.
You can imagine this profile
may be quadratic or something
like that.
And what we said in
the class, and you all
believed me except for
[? Kalpesh, ?] I guess.
What I said in the class is that
if you have a ray that enters
this medium sort of off
axis, like shown here,
the ray will actually
bend inwards.
So all of the rays will come to
a focus somewhere around there.
But [? Kalpesh ?] asked,
why doesn't it do this?
I mean, the rays here
seems to actually--
it seems to do the
wrong thing, doesn't it?
It seems to go towards
the high-index area,
whereas the minimum
path principle
would suggest that the ray
should go outwards like this,
towards the low-index area.
So the question is,
what will the ray do?
Will it do this or that?
We know from experience--
I mean, we know from experience,
from experiment, I should say--
that gain optics do focus.
So we know that physics
actually behaves like this.
But the question is, how is that
consistent with our description
of the physical system?
What is going on here?
So that is
[? Kalpesh's ?] question.
And what I said when he asked
it in class, more or less--
I cannot remember
exactly what I said--
but I said to properly
contemplate the answer,
we must consider
not just this ray.
If we just have this
ray, we don't really
know whether the ray will go.
But we also have another
ray, the one that is on axis.
Now these two
rays, they actually
originated at the same point.
Where did they originate?
At infinity, somewhere far
out to the left over here.
And what I said is that
basically these rays,
because this ray goes through
a longer optical path,
because it is entered
in a high-index medium,
this has too much,
its optical path.
So this ray actually
enters a lower index.
So therefore, it starts
with a sort of predicament
that points to a
smaller optical path.
So in order to
catch up, in order
to match the longer
optical path of this ray,
this ray, the sort
of off-axis ray,
must follow along at
a geometrical distance
so that the longer geometrical
distance times the lower index
kind of will balance,
will compensate.
So this is where we left it.
But then [? Kalpesh ?] came
back to me at the quiz,
and he told me, I
don't believe it.
You want to rephrase
your question?
AUDIENCE: No, [INAUDIBLE].
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: OK, so I
presented your objection well.
So first of all, does anybody
else from here or from Boston
have some additional
insight about this?
I can go back to the original.
We'll call it the
[? "Kalpesh ?] Question."
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: We didn't
hear the question.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Is your button pushed?
Yes.
You have to make sure
that the red light is on.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Yeah, in the standard
case of an interface,
we have a ray propagating
from left to right
and we have an interface,
which is top to bottom.
But in this case,
the interface could
be considered to be left
to right, couldn't we?
Because the refractive index
change is from top to bottom.
So the interface--
I'm just thinking that if we
consider the interface to be
from left to right,
then the normal
will be from top to bottom.
And still, the Snell's law will
lead us to the correct answer,
correct [INAUDIBLE].
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yes.
You can actually--
by the time you
reach here whether the
ray has already been,
you can make that argument.
Because now the ray is really--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
But the question
is, why should the ray start
bending inwards to begin with?
Why should it not bend this way?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: And if
it starts bending this way,
then Snell's law also said
that it should go like this.
So there's something amiss here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: OK.
So there's no doubt--
as I said, there's
no doubt that the correct
physics is this one.
The question is, is
our model correct?
Is our claim, all this stuff we
developed about optical paths
and so on, does it really
agree with the physics?
So I don't hear any-- any
other comments or objections
about this?
Or-- so let's go with
a little bit more care
through this argument.
What is happening.
Let's take out the medium,
so there's nothing now,
just free space.
So the rays started at infinity.
They're heading
towards infinity.
Everybody's happy with a
straight path, because clearly,
the straight line
in uniform space
is the shortest
between two points.
And clearly, these two rays--
they never really meet, but
we say they meet at infinity
at the left and they also meet
again at infinity to the right.
And they will have traversed the
same optical path by the same--
by the time they meet
again at infinity.
Now, you might ask, well,
what does it really mean?
I mean, after all, the
path itself is infinite.
What does it mean they
travel equal infinite paths?
Well, I can get, actually,
around this problem
pretty easily because I can
actually put some boundaries
to the left and to the right.
And I can keep these boundaries
at a finite distance.
Then you can definitely
measure the optical path.
Then you can start
moving the boundaries
farther away to the left and
farther away to the right.
The optical paths remain the
same as I move the boundaries.
And I can continue this
process until the boundaries
are really, really very far.
This is mathematically really
what we mean by "infinity."
So I can get around
this difficulty.
I can certainly talk
about equal paths,
even if the paths are
actually infinite.
This is sort of a
technicality, but nevertheless
an important one so we know
that we're on solid ground.
So I hope I have
convinced you that Fermat
is happy in this
case of free space,
because the rays
indeed propagate
through the minimum
path, and indeed, they're
all equal in terms of path.
Now, this is really
not anything new.
This is what I said before.
And basically, this says
that the longer geometrical
path actually gets to be
multiplied by a lower index,
so therefore, by the time
the rays meet again here,
they still have
equal optical paths.
Because the path to the left
is equal-- they both came
from infinity-- then the
two trajectories here,
if you sort integrate the
optical path all along,
you would get equal answer.
Are you happy?
Maybe push the button in.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Instead of a wave coming
towards a whole cross-section
of the GRIN lens,
suppose if you have a small spot
coming only towards the top.
So will it go towards
up in that case?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
So the question
is, suppose I take out this ray.
Will the ray-- will
this thing also focus?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: I think we have only
a single ray towards the top,
which is coming towards
the lower refractive index,
then it should go towards
the lower refractive index
because it doesn't need to
match with the same phase
as the center wave.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
OK, let's not quite
argue about a single
ray, because there's
no such thing as a single ray.
If you illuminate a very, real
infinitesimal optical spot
over here, as we will learn in
wave optics, what you will get
is not a sort of
straight line of light,
but you will get a very
strong diffraction.
So what will happen if you
illuminate a single spot here
is the light will spread
violently into the GRIN.
And then what will happen is
a kind of a complicated issue.
So the way, essentially
by claiming the fraction,
I got around the
problem that you're
posing, because as long as I
have a finite pencil of rays
coming in here, then the
same thing will happen,
because I can always
compare two rays that enter
at slightly different indices.
Then the same argument follows.
So this pencil will also
kind of focus in the same--
so basically, I can remove
parts of that ray diagram
and the same thing will
still happen according
to geometrical optics.
Diffraction says
differently, but according
to geometrical optics, I can
remove portions of these rays
and still have focusing.
There's another objection
that I haven't had yet.
I'm not finished.
I am not satisfied
that I answered
[? Kalpesh's ?] question yet.
And I see that [? Kalpesh ?]
is also skeptical,
and I hope someone--
I have another slide to
bring up the objection,
but I'm wondering if
someone will bring it up,
or maybe another objection.
At least there's one
objection that I thought of,
but there may be others.
AUDIENCE: Question.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why is it that
the ray on top bends
to slow down to
meet the ray that's
traveling through the denser
medium versus both of them
traveling to the less
dense optical medium,
because that could also--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's the objection.
That's exactly the objection.
So the objection is who says
that the central ray should
go straight?
I sort of silently
took it for granted
that the central ray
here goes straight,
and therefore,
this other ray has
to race in order to meet it.
Why don't the two
rays go like this?
Is this your question?
I mean, yes.
Why don't the two rays-- why
don't they both do like this?
They seem to be doing
the correct thing.
They seem to be both going
toward the lower index.
We know again-- we can argue
that this would happen,
but we know from physics
that this does not happen.
So what is the physical--
AUDIENCE: That can't
possibly happen by symmetry.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
OK, thank you.
Accurately, it is not
a question of symmetry
because indeed, in
this case, I assume
that the refractive
index is symmetric.
However, now let me see if I
can do this without revealing
my next slide.
However, I can make an
asymmetric index profile.
So this is a
simulation of the GRIN
with a symmetric
quadratic index.
Here, I made the
profile asymmetric.
So basically, this
is the equation here.
I should simply draw it,
except I don't have a marker.
Anyway, basically here,
the index of refraction
is a parabola that
has a different slope
above and different slope below.
So you see that even though
this is asymmetric, stubbornly,
the central ray
still goes straight.
Therefore, it is not
symmetry which makes
the previous case impossible.
AUDIENCE: But, well, I said
"symmetry," but if you go
to your next one, that
ray that's going straight
along the center--
is it gone?
Yeah, that ray goes
straight, doesn't it?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yep.
AUDIENCE: And that's
because there's
no transverse gradient in
the refractive index where
it's propagating, I guess.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: OK, yes.
That is true.
There's no movement to push it.
Yeah, and that, I agree with.
However, that really still
does not answer his question,
because the reason
momentum works,
the reason we apply
Snell's Law, for example,
is because we claim
path minimization.
So I suppose you
could argue this way.
I have another
argument, actually,
why this ray must go straight.
Actually, I don't know
if it must go straight,
but then another argument why
basically this is impossible,
why this is
physically incorrect.
AUDIENCE: If you do that, isn't
it true that the bottom ray's
path is still longer than
the top ray's path because
of the index of refraction is
low, and then it's just low
all the way, and--
yeah.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Exactly.
If you do that,
there is no way ever
that this ray will catch up.
Because this ray
now, not only is it
going through a higher
index of refraction,
it is also following a longer
geometrical trajectory.
So therefore, if these
two rays ever meet again--
they might meet at
a finite distance.
The way I drew them
here, at some point
they will meet again, or
they might meet at infinity.
They might somehow become
parallel and meet again
at infinity.
But no matter what,
this ray over here
has traveled the
longer optical path.
And now that is a clear
violation of Fermat.
So we basically arrived
at an impossibility.
So this is physically,
then, incorrect.
That is the reason why the
rays have to bend inwards.
And so the proper interpretation
of Fermat's principle--
and actually, the book has
an interesting discussion
about this--
we can claim, yes, that Fermat
minimizes the optical path,
but perhaps, at least
linguistically a more precise
definition is that
Fermat requires
that the path of the
rays is stationary.
Now, "stationary"
in mathematics--
what it means is that if
you perturb it in some way,
you will get a bigger answer--
if you perturb it in anyway.
So remember-- I wish
I had the marker.
I think I can just
use a pen, though.
Let's try with a pen, and
you guys tell me in Boston
if you can see it.
Remember with Fermat,
we did this analogy.
We said-- you can
see it, right--
we said-- I'm
sorry, I should have
said remember with Snell's Law.
Snell's Law says that
the ray must do something
like this in order to connect
this point to this point.
So mathematically,
what we derive
is that any other possibility--
this, this, this, this,
and also, why not this?
These are all different
possible ray trajectories.
There's a mathematical tool.
It's called "calculus
of variation,"
which does a miraculous thing.
It somehow compares all of
these possible trajectories,
and then it arrives at
the minimum trajectory.
And it tells us, no, no.
No matter what-- these are
infinite possibilities.
That you can imagine.
But this tool,
calculus of variations,
actually tells us
eventually that all of these
give us a longer
total optical path.
And the only true one, if you
wish, the one that minimizes,
the stationary one, is the
one that I drew kind of bolder
here.
So this is the proper
way to interpret Fermat.
It is not that a single
ray will actually
look for the lower
index of refraction.
It is actually
that when you have
a bundle of rays that
share a common beginning
and a common end,
then the trajectory
that these rays will follow will
be such that they're all equal,
and that this trajectory now
is stationary, in the sense
that if you were to
perturb it in any way--
if you were to move some
of these rays up, or down,
or bend them, or
whatever-- you would end up
getting a longer trajectory.
That's the proper
interpretation of Fermat.
So this is actually a
very interesting topic.
And I confess that
when I was a student,
I was also bothered by this.
I mean, the rays seems to
be doing the wrong thing,
after all.
It seems to be going really
the way it shouldn't go.
Why?
The reason is as we just
described-- because the path
has to be stationary.
The bottom line out of
this, which will actually
be useful in our
ensuing discussion
of Hamiltonian optics, is
that the index of refraction
is acting a little
bit like gravity.
Actually, it's
acting like gravity
more than you would think.
The index of refraction seems
to be attracting the rays, which
is, again, a little bit
counterintuitive if you
interpret Fermat
as a minimum path.
But after we went through this
explanation, it makes sense.
The index of refraction pretty
much collects rays near it.
Yes, there's a question.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
George, I think if you consider
the interfaces left to right,
the geometric works out.
And so if we assume any
ray coming like this,
going from left bottom to
top right, then it will--
it is going from a higher
index to lower index, which
means it will tend to increase
its angle with respect
to normal.
So it will keep
bending like this.
And at some point, there will
be total internal reflection,
and it will bend towards the--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's right, yeah.
Doesn't happen
here, for example.
If this ray continues--
AUDIENCE: And then
again, it will--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
It will kind of bend.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So maybe--
I mean, that's just another
way of looking at the problem,
that if you consider
the interface
to be normal to the change in
the refractive index, then--
yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Actually, that's true.
Snell's Law also
justifies this attraction.
I mean, the point that
is really hard to swallow
is why this ray starts bending
inwards at this interface.
After it has started,
then it has to fall,
because Snell says
that it should fall.
So that is consistent.
So really, this acts--
you can think of a
mechanical analogy, which
would be like imagine
that you take a tube
and you cut it in half.
So now you have
these hollow sphere.
And then you launch a billiard
ball into that surface.
What will the billiard ball do?
It will spin.
It will go down, and then up
again, and then down again,
and spin, and spin, and spin.
So basically, the
surface in this sort
of mechanical analogy, the
equivalent of the surface shape
is the index of refraction here.
And of course, the billiard ball
is subject to its own gravity.
And the surface--
how do you call it,
the [INAUDIBLE] contact
from the surface,
and so on, and so forth.
But the bottom line is that
this is a mechanical analog.
I'm sorry, this is--
whatever, the mechanical
analogy for this
is gravity, attraction.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Yes, provided
you define the gravitational
potential appropriately
in terms of the
initial refraction.
And this will actually come up
near the end of the Hamiltonian
lecture.
So I will show you
exactly the formula.
Did everybody hear his question?
AUDIENCE: No.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
OK, could you repeat it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was
asking, is the analogy
between the gravitational force
and the reflective [INAUDIBLE]
complete?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah,
and you have an answer.
OK, now that I have a
marker, let me also answer--
so in this case, what I did
is on the left-hand side,
we have the familiar
quadratic index profile.
So this is n0 minus the some
coefficient times x squared.
On the right-hand
side, what I did is
I chose an index that
[INAUDIBLE] like this.
I'm exaggerating,
but basically, it
is still a parabola on
the left and the right,
but has a different curvature
on the left and the right.
And the point here is
that the central ray still
goes straight.
Of course, this is
a terrible lens.
It does something
really horrible
back here, does
not focus properly,
and so on and so forth.
But the only reason I did this
is to show that the ray here
goes straight not because
the index of refraction
is symmetrical, even though
Colin's point is well taken.
I mean, the reason it
goes straight here--
again, you can think of it
in terms of Snell's Law.
It does not want to go
this way, because it
would bend to a longer optical
path then the ray next to it.
It does not want to go
down, because again, it
would end up with a longer
optical path with respect
to the ray below it.
So therefore, it
has to go straight.
Can you imagine a situation--
is it always straight?
Can I actually bend this ray?
What would I have to do to
make the central ray bend?
Actually, Colin
answered it already.
Yeah, they cannot see you.
Can you--
AUDIENCE: Curve
the whole profile.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: So you
have to put a gradient along
z in the index of refraction.
Then if the ray sees a tilted
interface, which basically
means a gradient of the index of
refraction here, it will bend.
Because again, Snell
tells it to bend.
But since there is no--
since here, the index
has no z dependency,
then the ray must go straight.
So first of all, thanks to
[? Kalpesh ?] for asking
this question,
because it turned out
to be a really,
really helpful one.
And in addition to that, today
we have kind of two more things
to do.
So I need to really finish the
Hamiltonian optics discussion,
and then we'll start
talking about wave optics.
So we'll see how far we go.
And I have to make some
announcements near the end.
So I will try to save about
five minutes near the end
for my announcements.
So last time, we were discussing
gradient index optics.
And just to briefly
remind you, this
is actually what prompted
the [? Kalpesh ?] question.
We went through this derivation
where we had the gradient index
element.
I will stop saying gradient
index it's difficult for me
to pronounce--
a GRIN light.
So we had the GRIN element, and
we did this simple derivation
which basically
said that this GRIN
element is acting like a lens.
And again, with our
newfound wisdom,
it is acting like
a lens by virtue
of the attraction of
the rays by the origin
of high index near the
center of this element.
And we also went through this
other case of axial GRIN.
And we also said that this is--
now that's interesting.
If you only have z gradient,
then it is still not a lens.
I'll let you think
about this by yourself.
In order to make
it a lens, you have
to have an x gradient,
the index of refraction.
So this case is
somewhere in between,
where you have a z gradient--
so the index is higher
in the front and
lower in the back--
but in order to get
optical power, that
is to get focusing power, in
this case you actually grind.
In addition, you
grind it to a sphere.
And we said that the reason
you do this axial GRIN here
is because you're
going to correct
for spherical aberration.
So if you compare the paths
now of this ray to this ray,
in this case, this ray goes
through a longer optical path,
because the index is
uniformly high here.
Therefore, it bends faster.
In this case, by lowering
the index of refraction
that this ray goes,
you actually force
it to go to a longer
geometrical trajectory.
Therefore, you're pushing
it further to the back.
This is another way to interpret
the way this element corrects.
You can interpret
it with Snell's law.
This is what we did last time.
But now, with our
newfound wisdom
on optical paths and Fermat, we
can also explain it this way.
I lowered the optical
path by virtue
of lowering the index here.
Therefore, the ray has
to go outwards in order
to increase its travel
distance, and still
maintain the same path
as the central ray.
So the net effect is that you're
correcting the bad quality
focus here that was caused
by the spherical aberration.
And I believe where we
left it last time is
we asked this
question, what if I
have an arbitrary
index of refraction
as a function of position?
What if this is not
quadratic, this is not axial,
this is some general function
of r, the Cartesian coordinate?
What then?
What is the--
I lost my train of thought.
What is the path of the--
what is the
trajectory of the rays
that go through this
variable index medium.
And I don't remember
how far I went here,
but we basically
took a turn here,
and we started talking
about mechanics probably
to some of your surprise.
Can you remind me,
how far did I go?
Did I actually finish
this example or not?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, we covered this.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: So I don't
feel like going into it again,
anyway, because this is
sort of good, old physics
101 kind of thing.
What might be a little bit
unfamiliar is this development
here, which some of you
may have seen, some of you
may not have seen.
So this is really not
doing anything spectacular.
This is a simple
mathematical manipulation.
So we start with the
equation of motion
for the mechanical oscillator.
So the equation of motion
for the mechanical--
I'm sorry not the
equation of motion,
but the energy for the
mechanical oscillator.
So the energy consists,
of course, of two terms.
One of them is, if you
wish, the elastic energy,
the potential that is due to the
restoring force of the spring.
And the other is
the kinetic energy.
And v is the velocity,
so v is basically x dot,
the first time derivative
of the position.
So this is one
thing that we know.
This is the energy
of the system.
And since in our model,
there is no dissipation,
the energy must be conserved.
I can also write an equation
of motion for this system.
And since it is a simple
spring force kind of system,
I expect my equation of
motion to be second order,
so there would be
something of this sort--
m x double dot plus kx equals
the force, the excitation.
So let's say that
this system is free.
There is no force.
So if it is moving, it is moving
because of a prior excitation,
which if I start
it [INAUDIBLE] it
will go on forever, because
there is no dissipation.
There is no place
for the energy to go.
If you get this thing moving,
it will go on forever.
But now, there's no force.
So basically, I can write
down the equation of motion
like this, as a
homogeneous equation.
So there's is a trick
that those of you who
use Matlab to solve differential
equations are very familiar.
And the trick is the following--
you break this higher order
differential equation.
You break it down into as
many as you need first order
differential equations.
Since this is a
second order equation,
you only need two
first order equations.
And the way you do
it is basically,
you write down an equation
that looks kind of stupid.
The equation says that x dot
equals v. This is one equation.
And then the other equation
comes from this one--
since x dot equals v, it means
that x double dot equals v dot.
This is the acceleration.
So the second equation
now comes from this,
that is, v dot equals minus
whatever k over m times x.
Now, I can define the
vector x v. And what
this set of equations
here has done,
it has actually connected the
first derivative of this vector
with the vector
itself via matrix.
And here is the vector
in its first derivative.
Here is the vector itself.
And what I have to put here in
order to make this look correct
is I have to put
1 here, and then
minus k over m here, and
then 0s, and then I'm done.
So again, if you
ever used Matlab
to solve an ordinary
differential equation,
you're familiar with this.
Matlab actually forces you to
rewrite your equation this way.
But it turns out that
this kind of method
actually preceded Matlab
by about a century,
because this is a standard way
of writing the equation in--
actually, I believe it was
Poincare who actually first
came up with this.
It's the standard way to derive
the dynamics of a system.
And this is not--
I don't want to spend
too much time with this.
But what this slide basically
points out to you is
the following-- that if you
take this expression here,
which I will call the energy,
but now we'll call it--
of course, you cannot see
it because it's hidden.
Now you can see it.
So this expression
is to call the energy
but to that I will
call it the Hamiltonian
and it will become
apparent in a second why,
but if you take this
expression, this is now
a function of the two dynamical
variables, the same two
variables that appeared in
this expression over here.
They actually get into
this equation, x comma v.
It's a bit of a funny
way to think about it,
but certainly you see x
here and you see v here.
And actually, I don't
like v very much,
because if I keep
using v, I will not
come up with the correct
set of equations.
I will replace v
with the momentum.
So that's a minor cheating.
Instead of v, I will
replace it with p.
So p, the momentum,
is simply m times v.
So I haven't cheated
in any major way.
I just did the simple
multiplication.
So if you replace p
here, then the equation
will look like this.
Nothing changes here.
This part will look like
1/2 p squared over m.
Oh, sorry.
OK.
So nothing major here.
The magic now-- it's
not really magic.
There's a good
reason for it, but it
looks like magic is that if
I do the following, if I take
the two derivatives of this
expression with respect
to x and p--
so if I take dh dx
and if I take dh dp.
Can you still see?
What do I get?
If I get dh dx, what is that?
It is kx.
And if I take dh dp,
I will get p over m.
So if I look carefully
here, this is p over m.
That's the velocity.
And this is minus kp, isn't it?
Wait a minute-- of
course, I know why.
I have v dot here.
Instead of v dot, let me
write it in terms of p dot.
If I do in terms of
p dot, I multiply
by m both sides of the
equation, I will get minus kx.
I don't have to
do anything else.
So what do I get?
I get that dh dp,
which equals p over m,
is this term in this equation.
And if I get dh dx,
which is kx, it's
actually this term
in this equation.
So basically, by taking
the partial derivatives
of this expression,
the Hamiltonian,
with respect to my two
dynamical variables'
position and momentum, I came
up with the equation of motion
decomposed in the
dynamical variables, Matlab
style, or actually
Poincare's probably
shifting in his grave--
Poincare style, in the way
[INAUDIBLE] dynamical systems.
So this is really what I
say in the top of the slide.
Of course, I say it in a
slightly more formal way.
And then the rest
of what I do is
I simply solve this equation,
but I will not do it here.
This is a simple
harmonic oscillator.
The mechanical system,
as I said before,
is a car that will
move forever, eternally
in a sinusoidal fashion.
And it's kind of
interesting, I guess,
that the energy alternates
between 100% kinetic, which
happens when the
cart, the particle
moves through the rest
position, because then it
is the maximum velocity
and has no potential.
It is the rest
position of the spring.
And it converts to
completely elastic when
it goes to the edge of
the range of motion,
because over there,
it has to reverse.
Therefore, it will go
velocity zero momentarily,
and the kinetic energy has
vanished at this point.
It has become all potential.
This is probably boring, because
this stuff is very well known.
What I really want
to do is I want
to establish a connection
between this very nice, very
well-known mechanical
stuff with optics.
So basically, what I will
do now is I will derive--
I will not really derive,
but I will show you
a set of Hamiltonian
equations that actually
describe ray trajectories.
And what is really
spectacular is
that, as you
pointed out earlier,
they will turn out to have an
exact mechanical analogy if you
use a certain equation for
the index of refraction.
So we'll get to that.
So there's two ways to derive
the Hamiltonian equations.
Does anybody know, in
the field of mechanics?
Does anybody know how we get
the Hamiltonian equations, what
is the process?
Well, I sort of just
described it over here,
but I guess what
I'm trying to get
to is, how did this come about?
Of course, it came about
from my physical intuition,
because I know that
to have a kinetic--
someone told me 1,000 years ago
when I was a student in school
that this is the case.
But--
AUDIENCE: It's the invariant
property of the system.
It's the total energy
we put in at the start.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Yes, so it is
the invariance of the system,
and also, mechanical systems,
they also have a Fermat
principle of their own.
If you recall,
mechanical systems
also try to minimize
their potential.
The trajectory that
they follow tries
to minimize their potential.
So a good example
of that is actually,
forgetting that this
is optics, imagine
that what you see here in this
sort of fancy-looking diagram,
this is not the index of
refraction, but this is a star.
Imagine that the center of this
[INAUDIBLE] massive object,
a massive gravitational
attraction,
like actually the sun.
And imagine that it's
not a ray anymore,
but imagine that that trajectory
is the path of the satellite.
This is convincing, isn't it?
If you allow the grayscale
to denote gravity now,
not index of refraction
but potential
due to the gravitational
field exerted by the planet,
then if I launch a
spacecraft, or a satellite,
or whatever in the vicinity
of this gravitational field,
as you know if you are a sort of
amateur astronomer or aspiring
astronaut-- if you
are, then you know
that depending on how you launch
your spacecraft, sometimes,
it will actually sort of
circle once and then escape.
That's very bad, because
it means that say,
if you're an astronaut,
you're going to space forever.
But also you know that if
you launch it properly, then
you can actually get into orbit.
And orbit means that
the dynamics here
is such that you will actually
start circling this object.
In fact, we never launch
spacecraft to stars.
Typically, we launch them to
planets nearby, but then--
So it turns out that
the trajectories
that these spacecraft
follow, actually
they also minimize their
"optical path," where there's
no index of refraction then.
It is just gravity.
But they actually do follow the
minimum path around the star.
And in fact, this has been
known for more than a century.
I mean, Copernicus even
hinted at that in his work,
when he computed the
orbits of the planets
in the solar system.
So these are very
well known stuff.
So what I will do now, then,
is I will actually drive you,
without really proving
anything, but that
will drive you to a set
of Hamiltonian equations
that describe the same
analogy, but for optics now.
So in order to derive our
Hamiltonian equations,
we actually need two postulates.
Now what does it
mean, "postulate?"
Do you know that word?
Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I
have a doubt regarding
definition of Hamiltonian.
Why can't it be some
other invariant quantity
like angular momentum
or linear momentum,
and energy in this case?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: So
you're actually there.
You're forcing me to say
what I didn't say before.
How did this come about?
This comes about-- and
I have to apologize now,
because I will throw a
lot of jargon at you.
This comes about from
something called the Lagrangian
principle.
So the Lagrangian
is very-- actually,
if you write the Lagrangian, it
looks very similar to this one.
Looks similar to this.
The question you're asking
the mechanical system
is, what is the trajectory
that the system will follow?
So we have a particle
or a set of particles,
and you ask what
is the trajectory.
There Lagrangian actually
looks very similar to this,
but with a minus sign.
And I never quite remember
if you put the minus
sign here or here, but anyway,
one of those has a minus sign.
And so what you do then
is you put this Lagrangian
into this integral.
And you say that the trajectory
that the particle will
follow actually
minimizes this integral.
Now, this has a very good
physical justification,
because this is
actually Newton's Law.
The way you get this
Lagrangian is you
start with good, old
Newton, which says that--
Then you multiply.
I haven't cheated.
I've multiplied
it with a quantity
that is hopefully non-zero.
And then you can write
it down as 1 and--
actually not quite 0
any more, but constant.
Now confuse my mind
with science somehow.
Well, anyway.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's a good plan,
because this is a
restoring force.
But anyway, how do we actually
derive the Hamiltonian?
So I don't know
what has happened,
but if you think about it,
this is now the Hamiltonian,
isn't it?
So by a simple trick on
Newton's Law, it derive--
that's not quite
what I was expecting,
but it happened anyway.
The answer to the
question is simpler
than I was expecting it to be.
So there is the Hamiltonian.
now why that and why
not the momentum?
That really has to do with
the Lagrangian, but let's--
It's clear what I
did here, right?
This is just a simple
manipulation that I learned
from Professor [? Jerry ?]
[? Wickham ?] at Caltech,
actually.
I think I skipped a slide.
Here we go.
So we were at this
word, "postulate."
What does "postulate" mean?
AUDIENCE: We accept
something without--
we say something and
we accept something.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's right, yeah.
So the postulate is a good way
to develop a scientific theory
in the following sense--
first of all, postulates
cannot be very complicated.
So it is something simple that
we accept with two caveats--
one is that we
accept it because it
has justified the observation.
So postulate had better be
something that has never
been violated to our knowledge.
For example, the
sun rises every day.
As far as humanity
has recorded history,
this has happened every
day, except, of course,
in the north above the arctic,
where some days the sun
does not rise.
So that's one.
And the second is
that the theory
that follows from the postulate
has to be self consistent.
So it has to be
mathematically consistent.
So typically the postulates are
things that I don't quite feel
like proving, but
they're good assumptions,
like assumptions that cannot
be very easily challenged.
So the assumptions
here, one of them
is that rays are continuous.
That really cannot be
very easily challenged,
because if a ray were to jump,
that would be really strange.
And I can quote a number
of physical reasons
why this would be
really strange.
For one is that relativity--
it means that somehow, a photon,
if we believe that photons
follow the ray
trajectories, it means
that somehow light within
zero time, actually
traverses a finite distance.
That is impossible, so
that is one good reason.
So if you accept, then, that
the rays must be continuous,
actually, it is only continuity.
I am not saying that the
rays are differentiable.
So the rays can bend like this.
So here, actually, obviously,
it is non-differentiable,
but it's still continuous.
So the postulate actually
talks about continuity,
not differentiability.
Piece-wise
differentiable, yes, it
is, because it is certainly
piece-wise differentiable here,
piece-wise differentiable there.
This is actually a technicality.
Functions that are not
piece-wise differentiable
are really nasty beasts, like
Weierstrass functions and stuff
like that, which normally we
don't deal with in engineering.
So basically, the
second condition here
is a mathematical technicality.
So we don't have
to dwell on that.
Now here's something that
probably as engineers, we've
got turned off by when we
learned it in calculus.
But it's actually a useful thing
that is called the "mean value
theorem."
And the mean value theorem
says the following--
says that if you are given
a continuous piece-wise
differentiable function--
so here it is--
so this is x.
This is f of--
so this curve here is f of x.
This is some function of
x1, x2, f of x1, f of x2.
The mean value theorem
says that according
to the conditions I just stated,
there is a point somewhere
in this interval satisfying
the following property,
that f of x2 minus x1 over x2
minus x1 equals f prime of x.
So basically, this ratio,
I can pick a point xi
somewhere in this interval
such that the value
of the derivative of a
function at this point
equals this ratio.
And of course, you can
realize immediately
that if you make the interval
very, very tiny, then
of course, you get the
definition of the derivative
itself.
But the mean value theorem
is a little bit more general.
And it is the mean value
theorem that I use here in order
to write this equation.
This is basically the
mean value theorem,
where the quantity of
interest that I applied
is the ray trajectory.
Let me back up for a second.
I should have started
with something else.
What am I really plotting here?
So the red curve is
the ray trajectory.
So I describe the ray
trajectory as a vector, Q.
So the vector is
a position vector.
This is the origin
of the coordinates
and Q is the position vector.
And then I parameterize
it with a variable s.
So basically, s is an index.
As I increase, as
I step through s,
I basically walk
along this trajectory.
So you can think of
s as time, as time
goes forward, the light
particles, if you wish,
are moving along this curve.
And at each point on the
curve, since it is continuous
and piece-wise differentiable,
at each point I can define
a tangent--
except, of course,
the point where
it is not differentiable, but
let's skip those for a moment.
In the point that
is differentiable,
we can define a tangent.
And this tangent
is the vector P.
So this vector P is actually
the momentum of the ray.
So since the tangent is
associated with a derivative--
in fact, in
high-dimensional space,
it is even more obvious because
the tangent really points
towards the--
it is the tangent.
Then this really
is an expression
of the mean value theorem for
the continuous and piece-wise
differentiable ray.
And of course, I can write it
down as a differential equation
by taking the limit.
And there is one element
that is sort of missing here.
That's the normalization.
Why did I pick to normalize
by the value of the tangent?
Let's leave that alone for now.
Let's assume that it
is correct, and see
if it will lead us to an
acceptable physical result.
So what I'm trying to say
is that the denominator here
is arbitrary.
I don't really need it.
I can throw it out.
It is a normalization
parameter, and I put it there
because with hindsight,
it would lead me
to a physically
acceptable result.
The second postulate
is a little bit easier
to swallow, thanks to
[? Kalpesh's ?] question,
because the second
postulate says that the ray,
very similar to a spacecraft
approaching a planet,
a ray actually is attracted
by a high index of refraction.
And the way we quantify
this assumption is we
say that if the ray
enters a region where
the index of
refraction is variable,
that this has a gradient.
So that's the gradient, in
case you have forgotten--
I hope not.
So if there's a gradient
in index of refraction,
the ray will receive a kick.
And the kick of the ray--
what the kick really means is
that its momentum will change.
Therefore, the
trajectory will bend
and the kick that is
a change in momentum
will be proportional
to the gradient.
That is the postulate.
And I will not do it
here, but if you--
it is a little bit of a long
derivation, I have to warn you.
I went through it
and I decided--
actually, I went
through it and then
I decided not to
put it in the notes,
because it is a
little bit involved.
But this actually turns out to
be equivalent to Snell's Law.
So if you want, I can give
you a copy of my notes
where I derived it,
but if you don't
feel like going through
two pages of calculus
of variations, then please
take my word for it.
This is actually Snell's Law,
but written in a funny way.
So that's, then, the sort
of variational version.
And we can write it down
as a differential equation,
and we get this.
So now, we're kind
of going backwards.
Now, we have two
differential equations.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why the
position variables
are different on both
sides, s and s dash?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
You mean the s prime?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, s prime.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Oh, the s prime
is actually the xi from
the mean value theorem.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
When you write it
in the variational form, s prime
can you be anywhere in here.
AUDIENCE: Right, right.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: I don't
know exactly where it is.
And very similar to
here, actually again here
I invoke the mean value theorem.
I didn't say that then.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
But of course,
when you do the
differential form,
it vanishes, because
the interval collapses.
So now what I have is actually
two differential equations.
One of them contains
a trajectory,
the other contains a momentum.
So this is basically the
two-dimensional analog
to the dynamical system
that I wrote here.
I have an equation
for the position.
This is it.
And I have a differential
equation for the momentum.
This is it.
This is the equation
for the position.
for the momentum.
I used q for the position here,
because that's a convention
in geometrical optics.
People use q, not x, but
q is the position vector.
Well, that's fine.
The question is,
is there anything
that is conserved here?
Did I derive any
sort of Hamiltonian?
It turns out-- and again, this
requires a bit of hindsight,
but I can pick the Hamiltonian
to be of this form,
to be equal to the
magnitude of the momentum
minus the index of refraction.
Let's write down the
two equations again.
So this is the equations.
And the Hamiltonian
that I picked
is H equals p minus n of q.
You can see now that
if I do the gradient--
now in the high-dimensional
case, instead of
the derivatives of
the Hamiltonian,
I have to take the gradient.
So if I do the gradient of the
Hamiltonian with respect to--
let's do the first
one-- with respect to q,
this is really what
I'm going to get.
And if I do the Hamiltonian
with respect to p--
what is p?
So for example,
if you do dH dp x,
you will get p x
over the square root.
And then you can follow
dH dp y and so on.
So therefore, the gradient,
which is defined as a vector--
So you can basically see
from this simple derivation
here that by this choice of a
Hamiltonian, the Hamiltonian
that I wrote here, I can
actually derive consistently
the set of
Hamiltonian equations.
So I basically
find that the dq ds
equals the derivative or the
gradient of the Hamiltonian
with respect to the conjugate
variable, the momentum,
and the other way
around for dp ds.
So this equation, then,
is the Hamiltonian.
It is not the only
one, by the way.
Hamiltonians,
they're not unique.
Clearly for example, I can add
an arbitrary constant here.
I can get another Hamiltonian.
And we know that
for energy also.
Energy is not unique.
I can add constants to it, and
it is still remains energy.
So you need the
reference basically
to decide which way to go.
But anyway, this is one
possible Hamiltonian.
How do we explain it physically?
Well, the momentum is a vector.
And what the Hamiltonian
says, that the difference
between the magnitude
of the vector
at the given position of
the index of refraction,
the difference has
to be constant.
I can pick this
constant to be 0.
Since it is arbitrary,
let me pick it to be 0.
If that is the case,
what I'm really saying
is that the momentum, the
vector of the momentum
is constrained to
lie on a sphere.
And that actually is known
as Descartes' sphere,
but it is not really--
Descartes was not the first
one to make this observation.
It was an Arab scientist
whose name is, I believe,
al-Haytham, who actually
made this observation
for the first time.
And actually, al-Haytham
also derived Snell's Law
for the first time.
So basically what the
Hamiltonian that we derived
says is that the
momentum of the array
is constrained to
lie on a sphere.
Now I did not go through the
slides when we did Snell's law,
but it is in your notes.
And you may have noticed it
if you were diligent when
you were studying the notes.
Because I actually showed--
this slide is another way
to derive Descartes' Law.
So what is happening here is
I have the familiar situation
of Snell's Law.
I have a medium of
index n to the left
and the medium of index
n prime to the right.
And in each medium, I associate
a sphere with a radius
equal to what
Descartes predicts.
So the sphere has radius n on
the left and another sphere
with radius n
prime on the right.
In this case, n prime
is bigger than n,
so the sphere is bigger
on the right-hand side.
So Snell's Law here is
derived by applied momentum
observation, which actually,
Professor Sheppard mentioned
in the beginning when
we were discussing
[? Kalpesh's ?] question.
And momentum observation
says the following--
that in the vertical direction,
up and down, clearly,
this geometry is invariant.
There's no change.
So therefore, the momentum
must be conserved.
The momentum on
the left-hand side,
which we denote as p
vertical, and the momentum
on the right-hand side, p
prime vertical, must be equal.
And since the momenta controls
Descartes' calculation
equal to this, then basically,
these vertical components
are obtained by projecting
the radius of the sphere
onto the vertical axis.
And of course, if
you do this now,
you immediately get Snell's Law,
because this angle is theta.
So therefore, this length
equals n sine theta
on the left-hand side,
and n prime sine theta
prime on the right-hand side.
So that is yet another
way to obtain Snell's Law.
And of course, you
might wonder what
happens to the momentum
on the [? back, ?]
on the longitudinal dimension.
That's OK.
You can have a
change in momentum
there because there
is a change in media.
So the change in media
actually corresponds
to a change in momentum.
And momentum is
conserved, with actually
means that the medium
here, if you actually
use the proper electrodynamics,
there is actually
a force applied in
this medium here
due to the change in
momentum of the light.
But this is beyond the
scope of the class,
so we'll not discuss it
in any greater detail.
So this kind of picture here,
with the Descartes sphere,
it also applies
to a GRIN medium.
So here is a medium whose index
of refraction is variable.
So you go from low to high.
Again, the convention is
gray means higher index.
And you can break it down.
Like we did, again, in the
beginning of the class,
we can break it down into slices
of progressively higher index.
And you can apply
Snell's Law, using
either Snell itself or the
succession of Descartes sphere.
You can apply it as
the ray goes down.
And then either because
it has too much momentum
or because it has to
satisfy Snell's Law,
these two statements
are exactly equivalent,
the ray must bend its path.
So this is yet another way to
justify why the ray is bending.
It is bending because
it must conserve
the value of this Hamiltonian.
It must lie on the
Descartes sphere.
But of course, in
the GRIN medium,
we have to be a
little bit careful
because this sphere
has a variable radius,
as you can see in this
diagram over here.
Now let's come to the other
question that was asked.
Is there an analogy between
mechanics and optics?
And because we're running
a little bit late,
I don't want to spend too
long with this analogy.
It's a very interesting one.
I'll let you study it.
And if you'd like, we can
also discuss it later.
But basically, the
analogy comes from this--
we go back and rewrite
the Hamiltonian equation
of the mechanical
system as a sort
of unassailable
kinetic energy term.
The first term over
here is clearly
the kinetic energy,
the term that looks
like momentum squared over 2m.
Then the potential-- we
wrote the potential before.
In the case of the
elastic spring,
the elastic potential was v of
q equals 1/2 k q [INAUDIBLE]..
That's one special case
of a restoring force,
of an elastic potential.
But it could be more general.
So we write it as v of q.
And then the rest
of the definitions
are basically straightforward.
The momentum equals m
times the time derivative
of the trajectory.
Anyway, like I
said, I don't want
to go through this
in great detail.
But basically, if
as a starting force
we use the index of
refraction squared divided
by 2m, where m is
like a fictitious mass
that we have to
assign to the photon,
then we would basically
get the one-to-one analogy.
This is quite interesting,
because it is really
acting like a spring
or like gravity,
but gravity is not
exactly the same,
because gravity
is like 1 over r.
So you have to make
an approximation
and blah, blah, blah.
But if you think
of it as a spring,
then you get basically
a one-to-one analogy.
So it's kind of interesting.
And the last thing
I want to say,
because it has a
practical significance,
is that once we write down
the Hamiltonian equations,
then it is very convenient.
In addition to all this
nice physics, and intuition,
and so on, it is
very convenient,
because we can just plug them
in Matlab and solve them.
So if someone is giving
us a graded index medium--
now whether it is quadratic,
or cubic, or whatever,
27th polynomial, or
anything for that matter,
we can just solve it using
this set of equations.
And here, what I did is I did
an example of a quadratic index
medium on-axis, off-axis.
You can see that on-axis
actually pretty good.
It is not completely
free of spherical,
but pretty close to free.
You can see it does come to a
very nice geometrical focus.
Of course, off-axis, it
has a terrible aberration
that we've called what?
How do we call this particular
aberration that we see here?
AUDIENCE: Coma.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Coma.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you use
the index of refraction
to correct for coma?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Yes, of course.
In fact, believe it or not,
this is a research project
in my group, which
says that suppose
you wanted to define
an arbitrary index
distribution here
in order to correct
for a given set of aberrations.
So someone is giving
you the specifications.
They say, I want to
eliminate the coma
for this angle of incidence.
I want to eliminate other
aberrations, for example
astigmatism and so on,
then in principle, you
can come up with some
index of refraction,
n of r, which if
properly chosen,
will eliminate this
specified aberration.
Now of course, that's
pretty easy, actually.
That doesn't need research.
It's kind of like a
computational problem.
But how do you implement an
arbitrary index of refraction?
That's difficult.
So we're actually
working on that in my group.
But yeah, in principle, you can.
In practice, with
commercial GRINs,
it a bit difficult, actually.
You would probably have to use
something more than a GRIN,
as far as I know.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: On the previous
slide, you said n has to be--
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Can you press
the button, please?
Can you press the button?
AUDIENCE: He is pressing,
but it's broken.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: On the
previous slide, you
said something about physical--
n has to be greater than 0.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
You caught me.
Yes.
Yes, I said that n has
to be bigger than 1,
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Better than 1.
The question is, can n be
less than 1 and less than 0?
From the point of view
of geometrical optics,
n is the speed of
light in a bulk medium.
And in ordinary bulk media that
we use in geometrical optics,
light is always
slower than in vacuum,
so n is always bigger than 1.
In a few lectures, when we do
proper electromagnetics-- also,
let me say that
so far, n has been
a phenomenological quantity.
That's another funny
word like "postulate."
What does it mean,
"phenomenological."
It means a quantity
that I have not
justified its physical origin.
I just pulled it out of a hat.
And I said, hey, you know
what, the speed of light
in the medium is less than
the speed in a vacuum.
So therefore, it
is bigger than 1.
Now, when we do the proper
physical origins of n,
then we will see that
indeed, n can be less than 1.
It can even be negative,
and that's another hot topic
in research optics nowadays.
So it is not necessary.
That's true.
But if you take it into
the mechanical analogy,
interestingly
enough, if you allow
n to go into these sort of
strange modern sort of regions,
where it is less than 1
and even negative, then
in the mechanical
analogy you would end up
with a negative energy,
which is kind of interesting.
It doesn't mean anything.
This is just an analogy.
It doesn't invalidate anything,
but it is kind of interesting.
And let me say upfront,
n becoming smaller than 1
does not mean that I
violate relativity.
It does not mean that
something moves faster
than the speed of light.
And as we will see,
just today, actually, n
is what we call the
"phase velocity."
And the phase velocity of
wave can be much greater
than the speed of
light, because the phase
carries no information.
That's sort of the
classical way to justify it.
So I can allow, actually,
n to be less than 1,
and am perfectly fine.
So it is not necessary, but
I should put a qualification
here.
Not physically allowable,
but how you say--
every day intuition
allowable, perhaps.
But of course, physicists
can do much better
than everyday intuition.
So let's resume for
another 20 minutes or so,
and we'll continue on Monday.
So what I would like
to do today is start
the description of wave optics.
So basically, we followed
geometrical optics
and it was good
enough to explain
a number of interesting things
for us, imaging systems,
gradient indices, and so on.
But geometrical optics also
has some serious failures.
The most important
of those is that when
light interacts with
very small features,
geometrical optics fails.
So for example, I used
it when I answered
[? Kalpesh's ?] question.
If you limit light to
a single ray-- that
is to an infinitesimal, small
spot-- than geometrical optics
pattern fails.
So the picture that it gives
us are completely wrong.
So in order to
deal with that, we
have to deal with light
as a wave phenomenon.
And there's an
interesting history there.
Newton was a big proponent
of geometrical or particle
description of light.
Some other
contemporaries of his,
like Huygens, Fresnel, and
sort of the Continental school,
they were proponents
of the wave theory.
And for many years,
the question remained
unsettled until Maxwell--
in the end, I think 1899, or
1896, or something like that,
James Clerk Maxwell, actually
a Professor of Fluid Mechanics,
came up with a set of equations
that proved very convincingly
that the light is a wave.
And then 10 years
later, quantum mechanics
proved that light
is also a particle.
So both were correct.
Both Newton and the Continental
school were correct.
So anyway, so you can think now
that we're basically now moving
from England to the
continental Europe,
because we're abandoning the
geometrical optics theory,
and we're moving to wave optics.
Now, waves, of course, are
a very pervasive phenomenon
that we see around us.
And they manifest themselves
in many different forms.
So we're familiar with waves in
seawater or rivers, and so on.
We're familiar with sound waves.
It's actually
Singapore's founder,
Lee Kuan Yew giving a speech.
So we can communicate
by sound waves.
That's another form
of a material wave.
So like water waves, sound
waves are material waves.
You set the air particles
in motion when you speak.
We're also familiar with
electromagnetic or radio waves,
not because we can see them.
These are actually not
something that you can touch.
But all of us, we use cell
phones, old-fashioned radios,
and so on.
We use them.
This is actually an
old-fashioned antenna.
It's not that old-fashioned if
you go to places like Europe,
like Greece, for example.
Many homes still have those
antennas in their roof.
So this is the way people used
to receive television signals
before cable TV.
And finally, there's other waves
that they're sort of not quite
obvious that they're waves.
This is a very interesting
geological phenomenon
in the Philippines.
It's called the
"Chocolate Hills."
There's a number, it's actually
hundreds of very small hills,
not very tall.
You might say, what
kind of a wave is that?
The hills are not moving.
Actually, they're not
moving in our time scale,
but in the geological
terms, they actually move.
And sometimes, this motion--
as you know, the
motion of the earth--
it can actually
happen in timescales
that are perceived by
humans, and then it's
called an "earthquake."
It's a very nasty phenomenon.
So the point is here that
waves manifest themselves
in many different forms.
Of course, I omitted another
important manifestation,
which is quantum mechanics.
Quantum mechanics says that
everything is actually wave,
including yourselves and me.
And every particle is
also described as a wave.
So electrons can be thought
of as waves, and so on, and so
forth.
Anyway, the waves are in fact
so pervasive that there's
no proper definition.
And to paraphrase something that
an artist said once about art,
he said that art
cannot be defined,
but you know it when you see it.
That's actually a very
good way to put it,
at least as far as
art is concerned.
But it's also true about waves.
Because there is
a great variation
in the way waves occur,
there's no proper definition.
What I attempted here is
the simplest possible,
all-inclusive definition
as a traveling disturbance.
As far as I can
tell, it is certainly
inclusive of all waves.
Of course, it
includes other things
that may not be waves, like
a car moving down the road
is also a traveling disturbance.
It is clearly not a wave.
But anyway, another way
to perhaps describe waves
is if you--
there's some evidences
of wave behavior.
And a very prominent one is
what you call "interference."
So what you're seeing
here is, we will see,
these are called
"spherical waves."
And we see two
point sources that
meet in these spherical waves.
And as they propagate
out, you see
this very characteristic
alternation
between bright and dark spots.
I have not even really
said what this thing is.
Is it a sound wave, a water
wave, an electromagnetic wave?
In fact, it could
be all of the above.
In all of these
cases, if I represent
as bright the high
value of the disturbance
and as black the low
value of the disturbance,
then these sort of
not quite periodic,
but periodic-like
looking behavior
is called "interference."
And when you observe this
sort of interference,
then it is a pretty
good indication
that you are actually
observing a wave phenomenon.
In fact, the reason Fresnel
in the Continental school
insisted that light is a
wave is because they actually
observed light interference
in experiments.
They observed the
light doing something
like that in the experiment.
So they said, well, wait,
it must be a wave, then.
Another phenomenon which is--
actually, it is related
to interference.
When we cover it, it has
quite a different name.
It's called "diffraction."
But when we cover it, we
will see that clearly, it
is not a new phenomenon.
It is interference
in this guise.
And diffraction basically says
that the geometrical definition
of shadows is incorrect.
So what you see here is a wave
that is impinging on a block.
So it is blocked
above and below.
And a small portion of it
is allowed to pass through.
Geometrical optics
would have you
believe that you
would basically get
a continuation,
unperturbed continuation
of the wave in the geometrical
shadow of this slit.
You can think of
it as a slit there
that the wave goes through.
But diffraction says
that's not the case.
As you can see, there's a
rather more complicated pattern
that emerges here.
And that is another evidence
of a wave phenomenon
that we will describe
quantitatively in great detail
later.
Let's take a look a little
bit in some more waves.
So for example, the first one--
it meets my definition as
a traveling disturbance,
but not a very interesting
one, because it is just a shape
moving.
The one that is on the right
is perhaps more interesting,
because now you see sort of--
it is more believable
that it is a wave.
It has some oscillation in
addition to the traveling
disturbance.
By the way, oscillatory
behavior is also
characteristic of waves.
But it is not
necessarily periodic.
In fact, you can
have a periodic wave,
but that's not very interesting.
It is the non-periodic
waves that
are the most interesting ones.
Now, if you let me go back and
play this movie once again,
that's not very interesting,
but what you will see here
is you will see
that it's actually
the same envelope that you
saw moving on this diagram.
You will see it is the same
envelope moving over here,
but inside, you have some
wiggles that are also moving.
And if you observe
it very carefully,
you'll see that the
envelope is moving
with a different velocity
than the wiggles.
The wiggles have a
name, by the way.
They're called fringes.
Can you see?
So the wiggles are
actually moving faster
than the envelope.
So this brings us
to the definition
of what I used once Professor
Sheppard's question about n
earlier.
I used the term
"phase velocity."
So what you saw in
the previous movie,
in the one that was in
the right-hand side,
was an envelope that was moving.
So here is the blue one.
That's the envelope.
And inside, there
was a sinusoid.
The sinusoid is multiplied
by the envelope.
A wave that is composed
of a sinusoid multiplied
by an envelope is said
to have a carrier.
So the carrier is
a sinusoid itself.
The carrier can move at its own
velocity, which, surprisingly,
is usually different
than the velocity
that the envelope is moving.
Why I say surprisingly, well,
some simple sort of [INAUDIBLE]
might have said, they better
move at the same velocity,
shouldn't they, when in fact,
the truth is the opposite.
More often than not--
in fact, you have to try
very hard to make them move
with the same velocity,
but more often than not,
they move at
different velocities.
So the velocity at which
the envelope is moving
is called the "group velocity."
The velocity at which
the carrier is moving
is called the "phase velocity."
And right now, we'll just
leave those like this.
Later, we will actually
derive them properly.
And we will see how
they come about,
and how they are defined.
But I can say for now,
without any proof,
that what we wrote in
geometrical optics, c over n,
that is the phase
velocity of the light.
If you were to put an
envelope on the light somehow,
which is done in special lasers
called "mode-locked lasers,"
you can have a light wave
that looks like this.
It has an envelope
as it propagates.
In those, the group
velocity is generally
different than the phase
velocity of the light.
Of course I said that earlier
that the other waves are not
very interesting.
Nevertheless, for educational
and analysis purposes,
they're simple.
So therefore, we start
with periodic waves
when we analyze waves,
and periodic is also
known as "harmonic waves."
And of course, in
a harmonic wave,
there's no envelope to speak of.
And therefore, there's
no group velocity
to speak of because
the envelope is flat.
There's no profile
going anywhere.
The only thing you have is
a sinusoidal disturbance
moving with the phase velocity.
Here you only have the
carrier, so the only velocity
to speak of is the
phase velocity.
That's a characteristic
of the harmonic wave.
And I will start putting
some notation here.
So the time, you can see that
time is run in index here.
And the horizontal
axis, I will call it z.
So we will stick to
z as the actual wave
propagation for a while.
So now let's do some math.
Since this is a harmonic
wave, I can expect
to describe it as a sinusoid.
And the sinusoid, in
order to characterize it,
I need to set a
number of quantities,
which have certain buzzwords.
So we'd better start defining
our buzzwords right now,
so we don't get confused
when we refer to them
later in the class.
So the constant that goes
in front of the sinusoid
is called the "amplitude."
The reason I use e as a
symbol for the constant
is because electromagnetic waves
are usually electric fields.
We will see that later, after
we do Maxwell's equations.
For now, this could be
any symbol, actually.
In fact, very quickly I will
refer to a different symbol.
But in any case, this
quantity that appears here
is called the amplitude.
Then the other quantity that
we need to describe a sinusoid
is the frequency.
But now the frequency, we have
to be a little bit careful
because there's two
frequencies going on.
You can see very clearly--
you can think of this as
a snapshot of the wave.
If I take this picture
and I freeze it,
I will get something
that looks like this.
So in this snapshot, the
axis is space coordinate.
It is z.
So the period that
you observe here,
the period that you
observe in the spatial
axis, it is called
the "wavelength."
We saw that before.
We did the definition of the
wavelength in, I believe,
lecture number one.
Now suppose I do
like this-- suppose
I fix my position
somewhere on this axis,
and I observe the value of the
wave as it is passing by me.
So now I'm fixed at the
given z and observe the Wave.
What do I observe if
I stand over here?
I will have another
sinusoid, don't I?
Because if I am sitting
here, the wave that I see
will be oscillating.
It will go in the
sinusoidal fashion.
It will oscillate
from a positive value
to a negative value.
So that actually associates
with a temporal frequency
of the wave, for which we
simply use the term "frequency."
So we'll say frequency, we
mean the temporal frequency.
And some people use f.
I prefer to use the symbol
nu for that quantity.
Finally, I have not
defined my time axis yet.
So when I'm looking at the
oscillation, if I'm fixed
and I look at the oscillation
of the wave, at time 0,
the wave might be
absolute positive.
In that case, it means
the wave is a cosine.
Or it may be 0.
In that case, it
means it is a sine.
And how do I correct
for this discrepancy?
By adding a phase delay,
by adding, for example
in this case, pi over 2.
So this additional
phase that I need
to add in order to
fix the origin of time
is called the "phase delay."
And for a while, I will use the
symbol phi for the phase delay.
So we defined basically all of
the quantities that we need,
except nu is not anywhere
to be seen in this equation.
What I've written instead is
this expression z minus ct.
And what is the meaning
of this expression?
AUDIENCE: Traveling wave.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
It's a traveling wave,
or another way to put it is a
traveling coordinate system.
If I write-- we have
no doubt what this is.
That's a sinusoid.
Now, that's a sinusoid in
an axis of coordinate xi.
If I now say xi
equals z minus c t,
where t is time, what I have
done is I've taken this axis
and I've started moving it
with respect to its rest
position that equals 0.
So this is what I've done in
the expression for the wave.
I've put this traveling
coordinate system
into the sinusoid.
And I don't really have
the frequency in here,
but you can see that
time, the time variable,
is in the expression
for the sinusoid.
So I can get the
frequency very easily.
And the way I get
it is by observing
that since the wave is
periodic in the time domain,
it will repeat one period later.
So the period is the
inverse of the frequency.
So if I look at this
expression over here,
let me rewrite the wave.
I can actually write it--
I haven't done anything,
just expanded the parameters.
So when this quantity becomes
2 pi or any integral multiple
thereof, the wave
will repeat, won't it?
So that will happen
when the time
equals the period of the wave.
Or another way to put it is
that 2 pi over lambda times
c over nu, where nu
is the frequency,
the inverse of the
period, here comes the pi.
Of course, the pi goes away,
and we derive something
that we've seen before,
c equals lambda nu.
And that is what we used to
call the "dispersion relation."
So this is how we
connect the phase
velocity of the wave with the
wavelength and the frequency.
And the phase delay is actually
a very important property
of waves, but it's
not a real big deal.
This is what I
was saying before.
AUDIENCE: George.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why is it called
"dispersion relation?"
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yes,
there's no dispersion
to be seen here, isn't there?
However, if I put, for example
an index of refraction, then
the index of refraction
is a function of lambda,
so then you'll get dispersion.
And of course,
another case is this
is the dispersion
relation in free space.
If you put boundary conditions
to the wave-- for example,
if you confine it
in a wave guide--
the dispersion relation changes.
I will not do this
in this class,
but that's another way where
the wave becomes dispersive.
So that is the explanation
of the phase delay.
I don't want to
spend too much time.
If it equals 0, you see this.
This means the wave is a
cosine, the phase delay is 0.
And then, depending on
what you see at t equals 0,
you may have different
phase delays.
Now, the reason the phase
delay is an important quantity
is because I want you to
look at it very carefully
and tell me what you see.
So anybody want to volunteer
what has happened here?
I'm going to play
this once again.
How are the two different,
on the left and on the right?
On the left, again, look
at it very carefully.
On the left, the
two spherical waves,
they're always bright
together or dark together.
So they oscillate,
as we say, in phase.
On the right, the two
waves are out of phase.
So if you look at
it carefully, you
will see that when one is
bright, the other is dark,
and vice versa.
I'll play it again
so you can see it.
And because of this, again, I'm
going to play it once again.
And now don't look at the
centers of the waves anymore,
but look at the
general patterns.
You will see that the
general patterns are actually
different.
They have the same
general shape,
but whether the pattern is dark
or bright at any given instant
actually depends on how
the two waves started.
So when we have-- this
is quantum superposition,
because I have waves
originating from two sources
simultaneously.
When we have a
superposition, the structure
of the overall wave
that we observe
depends very strongly on the
relative phase between the two,
the two sources in this case.
So with that, I
think I will stop,
and we will continue on Monday.
And I will not post any
new notes for Monday,
because what I think we're
far enough behind that we
should catch up on Monday.
What I would like to say is
that it is about time to start
the project for the
graduate class, for 2.710.
So soon, but not for--
basically by Thursday morning
Boston time and hopefully
earlier, I will
post in the website
a list of possible projects
and some instructions
on what to do.
And then basically, what I
would like you guys to do
is spend the next week
selecting your project,
and also contacting
your mentors.
Each project will be mentored
by one of my graduate students,
and some by me.
So possibly, I don't
know if Colin, you
might be interested
in mentoring one,
but anyway, we'll figure it out.
Maybe Sam from
Singapore, maybe not.
But anyway, we will assign
mentors for the projects,
and then we'll get them started.
The presentation is in
May, May 6 or May 7.
But anyway, the sooner
we start, the better.